I mean you play the infinite game for
the good of the game right right which
is you're in the hospitality industry
for the good of the hospitality industry
and for the good of all business and the
best companies the ones we love and
admire right they share
you know it's it's the ones who are
protective you know of what they because
they think it's a competitive advantage
and what they don't what they fail to
recognize is implementation is the
competitive Advantage not the idea
itself
execution is the competitive Advantage
but the ability to share the things you
believe in and the things you uh uh have
figured out yeah for the good of
business because we don't just believe
your employees should be treated well we
believe all employees should be treated
well you know and if we if you figured
things out so I'll tell you a story so
Bob Chapman is the CEO of a company
called Barry waymiller it's a company
I've written and spoken about quite a
lot especially in my book uh Leaders Eat
Last okay and you had the opportunity to
meet Bob Bob is one of those unique
remarkable leaders and the way I met Bob
is he'd read start with why and he sent
me a letter and saying I'm building the
kind of company that you've written
about
and I said I want to meet you and so we
had lunch in Los Angeles this Famous
Lunch
um where we were scheduled for an hour
and we both cleared our schedules and
spent the next three hours together
because we loved each other and I didn't
believe him I said you know I talk about
an ideal I I it's not realistic it's a
night it's a striving
he says no no I have it I said well I
want to see it to believe it so he
picked me up in his plane from New York
and we flew we spent three days flying
around the country to all these
different factories and it's a
manufacturing company right this is Blue
Collar some Union some non-union
manufacturing right
and what I saw absolutely astonished me
it blew me away I've never seen anything
like it
um and he didn't prepare anything he let
me roam the factory floor without any I
could talk to anybody I could ask
anybody any question I wanted
there was no window dressing and I was
absolutely blown away and I'll just tell
you one quick story that really
exemplifies uh and this one's I haven't
written or spoken about this one so this
one is I haven't talked about this one
so they have a machine that was getting
old you know this is a factory big
machine yeah
um that's getting old and need to be
replaced traditionally how large
machines are replaced is somebody in
procurement
fills out a list of requirements and
then goes in the market to find a
machine that fits a budget right that's
usually how it's done that's not how
they did it they went to the factory
floor to the two guys who work on that
machine one who's pretty young in his
early 20s one who's got more experience
uh neither of them have college
educations I think one had a GED
and they said to them you need to
replace your machine you have a budget
of 750 000 go and these two guys travel
around the country looking at and never
came back exactly
they now live in Tahiti uh they they uh
uh they gave them a budget not the money
uh
they flew around the country they they
looked at new and used machines and the
people selling the machine said they
never seen anything like it they've
never had anybody show up in overalls
climbing in the machine usually it's a
guy in a suit showing up with a
clipboard right you know they ended up
spending 650 000 so they were really
excited that they saved the company
money and that's their machine right
that's that I can guarantee that machine
will never break down right and the
trust and it makes perfect sense but
this is what one of the things that Bob
says you know Bob says is
we trust people who have college
educations who work in a back office and
we don't trust people who don't have
college educations what about their
education makes them trust where they're
untrustworthy because I know some pretty
dishonest mbas
you know uh
um and that's one of the things that Bob
did but the point was is we I went on
this wonderful tour with Bob and then we
finally went back to their corporate
headquarters in St Louis and the team
that had sort of built this culture was
sitting around a table and they were all
looking at me like this going isn't this
amazing like we built what you what you
wrote about
and I sat there and I said
I think you're the most selfish
organization I've ever met in my entire
life and they always sort of stunned
that I would say that I said look I
think it's amazing what you've built I
think it's absolutely incredible but how
selfish of you that you only offer this
thing this kind of thing that you've
built for 6 000 people what about the
millions of people who hate their jobs
who don't want to go to work every day
what are you doing for them
and it was on it was from that
conversation that Bob
opened the doors they now offer training
they now for tours like Bob now he wrote
a book about it you know he's now in the
speaking circuit yeah he's out there
he's now a public figure
and he's promoting this new way of
leading and this new way of thinking
leader means other people follow what
you do
and if your brand stands for something
that people want to copy
and you're leading the way then clearly
you are competing against yourself and
not them but let them compete against
you
and I think that the Four Seasons is one
of those Brands and I can't think of
anyone in the hospitality who has ever
done that who's ever reached outside of
their own
uh industry that others want to be more
like them